je vais mettre voit l'ensemble du projet
de loi après les explications de vote
alors j'ai d'abord monsieur brisson ah
ben non une surprise peut-être pas
peut-être pas mais bon mais si le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'émergence dans séparatisme
conséquence d'un radicalisation
islamiste a été depuis longtemps
formulées il comprend sénat comme en
témoigne la commission denquête créé en
novembre 2019 dont le rapporteur était
déjà notre collègue jacqueline eustache
brinio il est temps que temps d'agir
pour autant le texte et par une au sénat
n'était guère à la hauteur du défi à la
hauteur de la menace que constitue le
séparatisme
certes ils contenaient un certain nombre
d'outils bienvenue qui permettront aux
autorités de mieux défendre la laïcité
dans le service public ou de veiller à
ce que certaines associations ne fasse
office de faux nez à des mouvances
séparatiste
par ailleurs nos travaux en commissions
dans l'hémicycle ont permis d'améliorer
ces dispositifs
ce fut le cas pour le contrôle des fonds
de dotation des certificat de virginité
ou de l'endoctrinement dans les lieux
sportifs ou encore des dispositifs de
régulation des plates formes de lutte
contre la haine en ligue 1 mais il a
également été nécessaire de limiter les
dommages collatéraux engendrés par ce
texte risque évoqués par le président
bruno retailleau en discussion générale
saluons ici en particulier le travail
notre commission des lois de ces
rapporteurs qui ont été en mesure de
réduire ses effets de bords susceptibles
de frapper des organisations cultuelles
de bonne foi depuis longtemps bien
intégré au sein de notre république
de même le sénat à préserver la liberté
de choix des parents tout en améliorant
la lutte contre ceux qui voudraient
détourné l'enseignement à domicile de
ses objectifs au profil idéologie
séparatiste enfin surtout notre
assemblée s'est efforcé de combler les
multiples angles morts du projet de loi
lorsque le pouvait car si le 2 octobre
au bureau le chef de l'état avait dit
que ce que nous devons attaquer c'est le
séparatisme islamique
comment s'attaquer aux séparatistes
islamistes sans évoquer les questions
qui sépare qui enferme qui écarte les
tenues islamiques dans les services
publics les prières à l'université ou la
constitution de listes électorales
communautaire pour cette raison nous
nous félicitons de l'adoption par le
sénat de plusieurs amendements portés
par notre groupe
ce texte ne suffira cependant pas à
régler la problématique du séparatisme
après les travaux du sénat le projet de
loi est tout de même plus robustes et
nous nous en félicitons
pour cette raison nous voterons ce texte
espérons que nos collègues députés
saisir au en cmp cette eau polluée
opportunité de défendre vigoureusement
les principes de la république
merci la parole la parole est à madame
de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues nous avions en entrant dans
cet hémicycle d'emblée indiqué ce qui
nous semblait dysfonctionné dans ce
texte ce texte qui se fichait des
objectifs très ambitieux que nous
partagions mais qui finalement était un
texte de contraintes de défiance de
suspicion à l'égard des croyants des
associations de l'école du sport des
services publics et certains l'ont déjà
évoqué non quand deux sujets essentiels
la mixité sociale la mixité scolaire
bref la promesse républicaine qui avait
annoncé le président de la république
aux mureaux et que nous n'avons jamais
vu se réaliser
nous étions inquiets d'un certain nombre
de points sur lequel nous avons proposé
des amendements qui n'ont pas été
retenus nous avons souhaité conforter
l'observatoire de la laïcité
nous avons voulu que le contrat
d'engagement républicains soient
remplacés par la charte d'engagement
réciproque
nous étions inquiets des dispositions
visant les journalistes et la presse et
nous souhaitions revenir au régime prévu
initialement par le projet de loi
concernant l'instruction en famille en
souhaitant étendre le régime
d'autorisation également aux écoles hors
contrat nous avons eu à nouveau le débat
il ya quelques instants
mais finalement là
la droite du sénat a décidé de
transformer ce texte que certains un peu
cruellement ici avait qualifiée de tigre
de papier
entracte électorale puisque finalement
les vieilles marottes de la droite ont
été logés dans ce texte et devait être
visés les accompagnatrices de sorties
scolaires
les participants aux compétitions
sportives les drapeaux dans les
cérémonies de mariage le comportement à
l'université et surtout très symbolique
de l'alliance finalement entre le
gouvernement et la droite la suspension
des allocations familiales lorsque les
élèves étaient absents
bref vous étiez plus soucieux de
comportements vestimentaires que d'une
véritable lutte contre le séparatisme
pour tout cela nous nous y retrouvons
pas nous considérons qu exclure
certaines parties de la population les
mettre à l'écart en se félicitant d'
agir en accord avec la laïcité n'est pas
le combat de la gauche et pour toutes
ces raisons nous avons décidé de voter
contre ce texte et je dirai à mes
collègues du groupe et l'air que
finalement ils ont rendu un grand
service au gouvernement ils ont perdu
ils ont permis au gouvernement
d'apparaître plus raisonnable sur la
question des libertés publiques
alors même qu'un très grand nombre de
dispositions ce soir sont véritablement
attentatoires nous voteront donc contre
ce texte
merci madame benbassa monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre quel
collègue en 1905 c'est une loi de
compromis et de liberté qui est adoptée
la laïcité qui triomphe alors n'est pas
un autre culte elle n'est pas ennemi de
la foi ni de la spiritualité
elle impose le respect des croyants elle
ne saurait aujourd'hui justifier la
stigmatisation de temps de musulmans qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'islamisme
radical que pourrait être la réponse la
tentation au moins de certains de nos
concitoyens musulmans
face à tant de restrictions qui les
visent si ce n'est
le repli en reconnaissant les
discriminations et les humiliations que
vivent trop d'entre eux et en tentant
d'y porter remède
vous auriez ouvert une perspective
vous vous y est refusé sans rien apporté
de concret et d'honneur à la lutte
contre le terrorisme et en mettant
l'islam sous tutelle vous y avez mis
aussi les autres cultes tout le monde
paie sa part y compris nous vos
opposants que vous cherchez à tétaniser
avec vos polémiques électoraliste votre
islam au gauchisme votre gangrène et ça
marche
l'approbation quasi unanime de
l'amendement sur les réunions non mixtes
lille us bien qu' avant de voter ne
s'est demandé m'accuse la tombe de
trahir la république
avec ce texte vous étendez toujours plus
le champ du contrôle et vous mettez à
mal une vie associative si cher aux
citoyens et citoyennes de ce pays est
déjà en proie à tant de difficultés avec
ce texte vous brisez la fragile et le
fragile et précieux équilibré par la loi
de 1905 et transformer notre laïcité en
catéchisme
il ya lieu de s'en alarmer d'autant plus
monsieur le ministre vous avez ouvert
une brèche dans laquelle la majorité
sénatoriale qui ne rêve que de musulmans
invisible s'est empressé de s'engouffrer
pour aller plus loin toujours plus loin
toujours plus loin dans quoi dans
l'affaiblissement des principes vous
êtes conclure mais vous prétendiez dans
le monde
vous concluez raison le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire vente votera
contre ce projet de loi
merci nous avons encore 14 explications
de vote avant le ministre avait dit vous
pouvez pas me reprocher d'être directif
et puis après je veux dire que vous
protesté parce qu'ils ont autant
d'explications de vote où hp qui lèvent
la main
alors
la parole est à la présidente assassi
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre on au terme de ce
débat sur deux semaines un peu plus que
deux semaines d'ailleurs je veux redire
que pour notre groupe confortait les
principes de la république appelle à une
mobilisation pour qu'elle soit
quotidiennement incarner cette
république
les valeurs de la république sont notre
bien commun parce qu'elle décline ce qui
devrait assurer que personne ne soit
oublié par la république
alors monsieur le ministre votre projet
de loi a été aggravée dans ces contenus
par la droite sénatoriale et d'autres
groupes et surtout ce texte mais c'était
vrai aussi à l'origine de son écriture
déborde de la simple question religieuse
en l'état il divise il fragilise
il stigmatise à un tel point qu'il
sépare c'est un texte qui sépare nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens alors
tout y est passé pour arriver à vos fins
la suppression des allocations
familiales
l'interdiction faite aux mamans pour
accompagner les enfants lors des sorties
scolaires
les drapeaux étrangers lors des mariages
interdit le fantasme des burkini partout
sur les plages et à la piscine celui des
prières dont les couloirs des
universités la tutelle de l'ensemble des
associations et la possibilité de
dissoudre certaines d'entre elles et
j'en passe pour notre part comme
d'autres ici dans notre pays et dans
d'autres pays
nous combattons les indes et les
intégrismes le terrorisme les
terroristes j'oserais dire sans
prétention et pour ne parler que des
communistes que ces combats sont dans
d'autres adn à l'instar de tout ce que
nous menons contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme le patriarcat la laïcité
rime avec progrès social comme l'ont
voulu
c'est père fondateur c'est par la
promotion de la laïcité que la
république se retrouvera une république
au service de
toutes et de tous parmi lesquelles
celles et ceux qui sont souvent
confrontés à de grandes difficultés
sociales
en votant résolument contre ce texte les
sénatrices et les sénateurs de mon
groupe réaffirme que le redressement
républicains se fera par l'émancipation
et le progrès humain
certainement pas en s'enfermant dans des
politiques excluante discriminante
omniprésente dans ce texte
merci la parole de la présidente de
lattre si monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues après
vous l'avoir dit beaucoup de fois lors
du débat sur ce projet de loi je le
ferai une dernière fois ce projet de loi
s'inscrit dans la continuité des travaux
menés par la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur le développement de la
radicalisation islamiste et les moyens
de la combattre
lancé en novembre 2019 le rapport de
notre collègue jacqueline eustache
brinio avait été je le rappelle adopté à
une large majorité en juillet 2020 les
44 propositions 30 était du domaine
législatif
ici près d'une vingtaine sont
satisfaites par ce texte
je pense notamment à l'actualisation et
le renforcement de la police des cultes
à l'alignement des statuts légaux et
fiscaux découlant des lois de 1901 en
1905 à l'amélioration des contrôles au
sein des établissements hors contrat la
généralisation du numéro et haineux à
l'extension du champ d enquête
administrative pour des emplois
sensibles à la mise en place d'une
charte comme prérequis pour bénéficier
de subventions des collectivités locales
etc etc etc nous formalisons aujourd'hui
la sortie d'un déni collectif la
radicalisation religieuse qui touche
notre société ne concerne pas uniquement
la question du passage à l'action
violente il le fait de groupes qui prône
un repli identitaire d'une volonté de
faire prévaloir une norme religieuse sur
les lois de la république
nous parlons ici d'un projet politique
la réponse doit donc être politique
c'est ce que nous venons de faire ce
texte permet de clarifier notre droit
concernant par exemple la neutralité
notre service public et de ses
collaborateurs occasionnels
il permet d' armer des secteurs devront
faire l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière pour lutter contre des
phénomènes de radicalisation religieuse
comme l'enseignement le monde associatif
ou encore sportifs il répond à des
dérives actuelles qui nous ont
profondément marqué je pense au respect
de la laïcité dans l'enseignement
supérieur
suite aux positions inquiétante de
certaines organisations étudiantes mais
aussi aux mesures de lutte contre la
haine en ligne directement inspiré de
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit il s'agit
également d'y apporter une réponse
proportionnée
l'amendement de l'article 21 en est le
symbole l'enseignement à domicile ne
représente en rien une véritable menace
séparatiste mais son contrôle et son
suivi n'était pas adapté il devait donc
être optimisé c'est chose faite
pour toutes ces avancées je voterai ce
texte monsieur le président hors temps
de parole je souhaite modifier un vote
sur le scrutin numéro 108 mes collègues
christian bilhac bernard fialaire et
jean claude requier ne souhaitait pas
s'abstenir mais voté pour
merci tenir compte de cette mise au
point dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin
je vous remercie merci acté données de
votre mise au point il sera publié au
journal officiel et figurera dans
l'analyse politique du scrutin concerné
et la parole est à monsieur mohamed
swahili
merci monsieur le président ce ministre
mes chers collègues nous voici au terme
de l'examen du projet de loi de ce
projet de loi tant attendu un texte
relevant d'une ambition de répondre aux
forces de fragmentation exercées par des
lois particulières sur la norme commune
un texte s'inscrivant dans la continuité
de l'esprit libéral de la loi de
séparation de 1905 avec des mesures
utiles sur la neutralité des services
publics
l'école républicaine la lutte contre la
haine en ligne ou la protection de la
dignité de la personne humaine des
mesures techniques et bienvenue aussi
visant la transparence des financements
étrangers et l'incitation des
associations à rejoindre le régime de la
loi de 1905 pour nos activités
cultuelles
le texte issu de notre commission
s'efforcer initialement de partager cet
esprit notre commission n'avait pas
laissé passer deux mesures ne
concourront pas réellement un objectif
du projet de loi notamment aucune
disposition sur l'extension de
l'obligation de neutralité religieuse
aux usagers du service public à l'espace
public voire il faut bien le rappeler
aux élus locaux
le texte est issu de nos débats en
séance à 1
bourg introduit plusieurs dispositions
sur ce sujet des signes religieux
nous le regrettons au regard de la
conception du principe de laïcité dans
la continuité de la loi de séparation de
laïcité qui implique la neutralité de
l'état mais également la liberté de
conscience par la neutralité de tous ni
l'éviction du religieux de l'espace
public il est d'ailleurs un peu
paradoxal de retrouver cette volonté
d'étendre le principe de neutralité chez
certains de nos collègues qui dénonçait
le texte initial comme remettant en
cause les équilibres de 1905 et comme
marquant une défiance vis-à-vis du fait
religieux
nous nous interrogeons également sur la
cohérence de modification des
dispositions relatives à l'éducation
pourquoi soutenir et mécanismes de
suppression des allocations familiales
en cas d'absentéisme répété et dans le
même temps rejeté l'article 21 de nature
justement affermir le respect de
l'instruction obligatoire
nous ne saisissions elle regarde ses
réserves importantes mais également des
dispositions utiles maintenue par le
sénat et dans la perspective de la cmp
notre groupe s'abstiendra merci la
parole est à monsieur bonne carrière oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
préambule pardon en préambule de ce
débat j'évoquais un texte qui ne nous
laisserait pas eynden et son examen
effectivement confirmé cette
appréciation et ça s'explique aisément
c'est un texte qui est mal née il est
mal née en ce sens que il vise une seule
partie de la population alors que ces
mesures sont général il va concerner
tous les biens faisant alors que bien
entendu il ne viserait que les
malfaisants et c'est aussi un texte qui
montre une forme de malaise par rapport
au fait religieux
cet accent je ne suis pas également sûr
qu'il est bien évolué dans la mesure où
nous avons assisté et les votes ont été
ce qu'ils on est traité
à une forme de législation par
surenchère une surenchère sécuritaire
dont je vois mal quelle va être l'issue
puisqu'elle nous a conduits en
particulier liciencié mp je crois que
personne n'ait de diffusion le dessus
mais chacun mesure combien elle nous a
conduits à adopter des mesures qui sont
clairement inconstitutionnel ce qui
reste quand même pour le législateur un
élément d'étonnement je voudrais
également évoqué une forme de
législation et également par par
interdiction c'est un texte qui crée
cinq infractions pénales nouvelle je
laisse de côté les aggravations de peine
et qui crée 33 interdiction
rien que rien que cela et c'est
finalement ce qui est étonnant dans ce
texte
c'est un texte qui nous dit tellement
peu sûr ce qui permet de faire société
et qui permet à une société d'avancé et
qu'ils nous ont dit tellement sûr au
contraire le manque de confiance qui
existe dans notre société et je ne vois
pas cela monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues membres de la majorité de
sénatoriales
en quoi ce texte est à dire élèves
notre société vous comprenez le sens de
mon vote qui s'extrait bien sûr à titre
personnel merci la parole est maintenant
aux prises dans laurent
merci monsieur le président pourquoi
comme tous les membres du groupe crc au
je voterai contre cette loi
il y a évidemment toutes les surenchères
sécuritaires raciste août les amalgames
qu'on a entendu tout au long du débat et
tous les amendements discriminatoire qui
ont été avec à l'initiative de la droite
mais il n'y a pas seulement les
amendements de la droite il y à la
philosophie politique du projet qui pose
problème
cette loi ne conforte pas les principes
de la république contrairement à ce que
dit son titre elle les fragilisent dans
bien des domaines
je me serais je me faisais une réflexion
quelqu'un qui ne connaîtraient pas la
loi de 1905 et que nous aurions à mener
dans cet hémicycle pour écouter nos
quinze jours de débats et on lui aurait
demandé mais c'était quoi la loi de 1905
ils ne nous auraient évidemment pas
répondu c'est une loi de liberté une loi
d'égalité des droits
une loi de séparation des églises et de
l'état pour libérer la liberté de
conscience
il nous aurait dit la loi de 1905 c'est
une loi de contrôle d'ordre public que
vous êtes en train de renforcer de
toutes ses dispositions pour contrôler
les associations contrôler les
fédérations sportives contrôler les
libertés contrôler tous les cultes
contrôle et évidemment les musulmans de
france
cette loi en fait elle ouvre la porte à
l'arbitraire dans beaucoup de domaines
et c'est extrêmement inquiétant
elle a raté l'objectif qui était énoncé
conforter les principes de la république
qui aurait dû conduire à une toute autre
ambition mais je veux le dire aussi
c'est le dernier mot que je veux dire
elle est passée à côté de bien des
débats que mériterait une lutte efficace
contre l'islamisme politique et pour
prendre un seul exemple un seul exemple
nous avons beaucoup parlé des états
étrangers
mais en vérité nous en avons bien peu
parlé parce que si nous voulions ouvrir
ce débat il y aurait beaucoup de choses
à dire sur nos relations effectivement
internationale qui continue des
relations de complicité avec beaucoup
d'états qui donne
monde organise l'islamisme politique et
oppriment leur propre population est
souvent des populations musulmanes dont
leur propre aux états et de tout cela
nous n'avons jamais parlé
il y a eu beaucoup d'hypocrisie à propos
de ça dans le débat et si nous voulions
ouvrir un véritable débat sur cette
question alors là peut-être que nous
parlions parle parler d'une lutte
efficace contre l'islamisme politique
merci la parole à monsieur reichardt
merci monsieur le président ce ministre
mes chers collègues à titre personnel je
vais voter pour ce texte avec les
amendements introduits
heureusement au sénat même si je ne suis
pas sûr que celui ci atteignent le but
indiqué au départ soit la lutte contre
le séparatisme en qualité de corée pas
co rapporteur du rapport élaboré il y a
trois ans maintenant par la mission
sénatoriale sur l'islam nous avions
pointé plusieurs mesures fortes à
prendre qui ne figurent pas dans ce
texte
ainsi plusieurs flux financiers opaques
dans la sphère religieuse islamique
le halal le hajj aurait nécessité que
l'on s'en préoccupe sérieusement ce
n'est pas le cas alors même que l'on a
pris les mesures fortes sur les
financements les associations cultuelles
pour lutter contre cette absence de
transparence financière
pas seulement naturellement dans les
associations cultuelles islamique mais
dans tous les cultes de même après
l'échec de mon amendement sur
l'obligation d'une formation pour les
ministres du culte on continuera à
assister à des prêches et autres
discours prônant un islam radical dans
certaines mosquées et ceci me paraît
constituer un vrai manque dans le
solutionnement aurait assurément été
essentielle pour un développement
harmonieux de l'islam par contre bien
entendu je me félicite que le texte
n'ait pas apporté de modifications
majeures monsieur le ministre je voulais
dit tout à l'heure
la situation des cultes en
alsace-moselle je voudrais une nouvelle
fois vous remercier de votre
compréhension à cet égard enfin pour
conclure je souhaite que ce texte donne
lieu à un suivi par le parlement
certains amendements portés sur la
nécessité de rapport à partir du moment
mes chers collègues ou des contrôles
vont être assurés sur un certain nombre
d'obligations qui doivent être mises en
oeuvre désormais par les associations
cultuelles notamment il serait
souhaitable que le parlement puisse être
tenu au courant du suivi afin de prendre
le moment venu le cas échéant les
mesures correctrices nécessaires
je vous remercie merci monsieur ozu
liasses merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous vous avions dit juste avant le
débat que les seules séparatistes les
vrais séparatiste était ici dans ce
canton de l'hémicycle
les défenseurs de la séparation de
l'église et de l'état qui poursuivent
l'oeuvre de jaurès et brillant qui a
abouti à la loi de 1905
ils sont ici dans ce canton et le débat
l'a bien montré et je crois qu'il était
intéressant à ce titre la loi de 1905
ça a été dit je le répète c'est la
liberté conscience la liberté de culte
la liberté d'association
nous avons défendu ici les cultes nous
regrettons vivement que par votre loi
vous avez porté ici un texte néo
concordataire qui va soumettre les
cultes un régime d'autorisation qui n'a
absolument qu dans l'esprit de 1905 nous
regrettons vivement que dans cet
hémicycle la défense des églises et été
réalisée par des sénateurs qui se
trouvent dans ce canton la droite le
gouvernement ont été muets muet pour
défendre l'essentiel
à nos yeux la liberté de conscience la
liberté de culte la liberté des
religions en 1905
clémenceau disait la séparation n'est
pas fait
les commencer lé in fihri nous avons
essayé de poursuivre cette offre vous
vous y êtes absolument refuser
vous avez refusé toute évolution sur la
guyane sur saint pierre et miquelon sur
l'alsace moselle etc vous acceptez la
loi de 1905 mais on l'a figeant dans son
état de 1905
tout en acceptant toutes les dérogations
possibles
finalement nous voyons que les
fondements des oppositions sur la loi de
1905 dans cet hémicycle restent les
mêmes vous vous devez vous êtes contre
la loi de 1905 nous ici à gauche nous la
défendons nous sommes les seuls vrais
laïque votre défense de la laïcité et
opportuniste conjoncturel est finalement
très un centre est insincère
nous reprendrons seul le flambeau la
laïcité pour donner aux deux premiers
articles de la loi de 1905 une valeur
constitutionnelle une valeur universelle
et nous demandons à tous les
républicains de nous rejoindre dans ce
combat
merci monsieur le président et la parole
est à monsieur dessus merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues deux
semaines que nous admet nous examinons
ce texte de semaine que la boîte de
pandore est ouverte
la boîte à surenchère identitaire qui a
fait sauter un certain nombre de digue
entre la droite et l'extrême droite
interdiction du voile pour les
accompagnatrices scolaire et pour les
mineurs interdiction des drapeaux
étrangers lors des mariages contrôler
les associations et des sportifs
limitation de la liberté d'expression à
l'université suspension des allocations
familiales en cas d'absentéisme scolaire
n'en jetez plus la liste est très longue
deux semaines de dérive identitaire bien
éloigné du sujet de séparatisme de
semaine qui ont contribué à installer un
climat de division et de haine dans
notre pays une haine qui a explosé
notamment ce week-end avec différentes
attaques ou de projets d' attaque
déjouée contre des mosquées
ne nous y trompons pas c'est bien le
gouvernement qui a ouvert la voie avec
ce texte qui bouleverse les équilibres
des grands textes qui structurent notre
république
il est d'ailleurs intéressant qu'à
droite sénatoriale est tout de même eu
un ou deux moments de lucidité dès lors
qu'il s'est agi de défendre
l'instruction en famille ou le concordat
attaquant ce texte qui venait remettre
en cause des libertés la liberté
d'instruction plus que centenaire ou des
spécificités locales
un impact mal maîtrisée qui remet en
cause des grandes libertés républicaines
ken une critique qu'on peut faire sur un
grand nombre d'articles de ce texte
outre son côté stigmatisant ce projet de
loi offre peu d'outils pour lutter
efficacement contre le salafisme où les
séparatismes il passe à côté des grands
dangers notre république le séparatisme
social est une république ne tient plus
ses promesses de fraternité d'égalité et
de liberté
reprenons emmanuel macron dans son
discours des mureaux il disait alors
nous aimons la république quand elle
tient ses promesses d'émancipation
quel projet d'une république
émancipatrice quand les inégalités
sociales et territoriales ne sont pas au
coeur de la ligue contre le séparatisme
quel projet d'émancipation contre les
principes principaux acteurs sociaux de
la république sont placées sous un
régime de contrôle global
quel projet d'émancipation quand on
impose la suspicion générale sur les
milliers de bénévoles qui font vivre le
monde associatif ou sportifs nous sommes
radicalement dévoué à une conception
ouverte et accueillante de notre nation
une vision qui est celle de l'esprit
républicain depuis 89 10 789 les
ayatollahs les fanatiques ceux qui ont
abandonné la république ou qui en font
une cible à abattre sont dans le camp de
ceux qui dressent les uns contre les
autres
ce texte impose une vision la laïcité
qui est n'est plus une garantie de la
liberté républicaine de croire ou de ne
pas croire mais devient une arme pointée
contre les religions nous nous
opposerons à ce texte dans son
intégralité qui est le symbole d'une et
riffs gobal qui instrumentalisent
l'idéalisme l'idéal républicain
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
hervé monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
l'instant où nous allons voter ce texte
d'abord vous rappeler une petite
histoire personnelle il ya cinq ans
j'étais maire d'une commune de 5000
habitants haute savoie et nous avons dû
fermer une mosquée une école coranique
c'est bernard cazeneuve qui a eu le
courage de fermer cette mosquée cette
école coranique
résultat ça j'ai été menacé de mort
protégé par la gendarmerie pendant près
d'un mois et nous avons dû nous élus de
cette commune faire front à skis et
l'islamisme radical sur le terrain en
haute savoie
donc le séparatisme la dérive sectaire
d'une religion permettez moi de vous
dire que je la connais que je les ai
prouvé et que j'en ai ressenti toutes
les conséquences donc monsieur le
ministre quand j'ai vu votre texte
arrivait je l' ai vu d'un très bon oeil
et je me suis dit que c'était le moment
d'aller parler de sujets
sociétés qui sont des sujets importants
et qui touche à cette question de la
dérive sectaire que l'on connaît dans
une ou dans plusieurs religions mais une
en particulier
et puis le texte de l'assemblée
nationale est arrivé ici présent la
commission des lois les deux rapporteurs
ont fait un travail une oeuvre pour
essayer de trouver de nouveaux
équilibres pour ne pas trop atteindre à
la liberté de culte dans d'autres pays
et on cela globalement j'ai plutôt été
amenée à soutenir leurs efforts mais je
sentais déjà que des dérives commençait
à poindre déjà dans nos débats en
commission
et puis il ya eu ces quinze jours de
séance ou alors là sont apparus tout un
tas je parle juriste d'horreur juridique
de musée des horreurs
on est allés nous ressortir tout ce
qu'il y a de pire et de médiatiquement
pire monsieur tête c'était un objectif
médiatique et donc à plusieurs reprises
j'ai été amené à me positionner contre
ces dérives là avec des fortunes
diverses
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on fait pour un
de ces mesures trop éloignés même
de la notion de séparatisme on est très
très loin de l'objectif
on est quand on parle pardon je
reconnais mais quand on parle de saint
pierre et miquelon contrepartie des
allocations familiales
on est quand même très loin de l'objet
même du texte et donc voilà
pour toutes ces raisons et monsieur
prison retailleau en conscience comme
vous avez été amené à le faire à
d'autres à d'autres reprises en
conscience et essayer au monde au
personnel je ne voterai pas ce texte
dans sa mouture sénatoriales merci
monsieur ravier merci monsieur le
président vous avez raison madame
rossignol vous avez raison nous sommes
dans l'embarras bien qu'en ce qui me
concerne je ne me sente ni responsable
ni coupable pour avoir fait partie de
ceux qui ont sonné le tocsin il ya bien
longtemps
oserais je dire que j'ai prêché que j'ai
prêché dans le désert
dans le désert du politiquement correct
si nul n'est prophète en son pays
monsieur le ministre nous il peut être
entendu parce qu'ils refusent d'écouter
pour avoir fait preuve d'idéologie en
matière migratoire d'angélisme pour
avoir cru qu'il y avait un islam
de france alors qu'il n'y a qu'un seul
et même islam en france et qui produit
sans doute involontairement un virus le
virus de l'islamisme et ses militants
qui chaque jour dans tous les corps de
la dation gangrène notre pays
école primaire secondaire universitaire
entreprises sport culture et même et
même servi par les idiots utiles
incertain et mystique
voilà le bilan voilà le bilan de cette
idéologie monsieur kader vous avez eu
raison de pointer du fait que la droite
n'allait pas jusqu'au bout de sa logique
est que ne nommer pas le mal qu'on
n'allait pas au bout du processus
intellectuel et d' analyse de ce
phénomène et qu'effectivement monsieur
laurent vous avez pointé cette stratégie
de la droite qui consiste à reposer sur
l'hypocrisie une hypocrisie qui s'est
matérialisé ici qui s'est concrétisée
par le refus de voter mais amendement
qui était pourtant les mêmes que ceux
présentés plus loin par nos chers
collègues de droite
c'est donc une attitude non pas
d'intérêt général d'intérêt national b
d'intérêts partisans ce à quoi moi je me
suis refusé car j'ai voté tous les
amendements qui me passe qui me
paraissait être pertinent qui me
paraissaient s'inscrire dans la dans
l'intérêt général
alors aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
vous êtes dans la réaction dans la
précipitation
vous avez encore proposé un amendement
de dernière minute k vous réagissez à
l'actualité
vous n'avez jamais rien voulu voir venir
vous êtes vous aussi un prisonnier du
politiquement correct est aujourd'hui
obligé de vous coller à l'actualité
plutôt que d'agir en amont en
identifiant on va dire en stigmatisant
quand je le revendique encore une fois
stigmatisé les islamistes et pourtant
l'urgence et vous ne le faites toujours
pas car tu m'aimes ce moment là vous ne
l'utilisez pas dans la loi je me fais
pas d'illusion c'est ici parce que
l'assemblée nationale passera à l'amour
ce coup de menton du gouvernement et ce
coup de com de la majorité je voterai et
je conclu monsieur le président merci
pour votre patience
mais malgré ces imperfections il y à
quelques avancées et dans l'intérêt
général dans l'intérêt national je
voterai ce projet de loi merci la parole
est à madame v rien merci monsieur le
président cette loi la première pour
laquelle j'étais rapporteur reprend
beaucoup de préconisations qui étaient
dans des rapports sénatoriaux pour
justement essayer de régler des
séparatismes pas forcément un
séparatisme et il me semble que elle
permet d'avancer le travail en
commission et je remercie stéphane
pieds-noirs et jacqueline eustache
brinio avec lesquels nous avons
travaillé pour essayer justement de
rendre ce texte plus constructif encore
notamment en remettant la liberté
d'instruction et remettant le régime
déclaratif plutôt que le régime
d'autorisation en desserrant
effectivement certains vient du culte et
en essayant de renforcer le fait que
l'on favorise vraiment et je crois que
c'est un point très important de ce
texte le passage des associations de
1900 à 1950
on sait qu'on ne peut pas les y obliger
mais l'important c'est de le favoriser
là aussi ça faisait partie des
préconisations sénatoriales donc même si
certains collègues qui se sont exprimés
ont quelques prévention sur le texte
issu des travaux de l'hémicycle la
majorité de notre groupe il ya trouvé
beaucoup plus de points positifs que
négatifs et il me semble plus que de
détruire 1905 c'est au contraire une
continuité qui rappelle que en france
nous avons une véritable séparation
entre la religion et le politique entre
le spirituel et le temporel
et je crois que cette loi le rappel et
le rappelle à tous les cultes qui
n'était pas forcément présents en 1905
mais c'est en cela qu'il me semble que
ça favorise réellement l'esa
conforterait réellement les principes de
la république
merci la parole est au président requier
merci monsieur le président monsieur
michel collègues le sa génèse à
l'automne dernier jusqu'à ce que débute
l'examen de ce projet de haut à prendre
a semblé le groupe rdse se positionner
presque unanimement en sa faveur
l'oeil alors qu'il présentait nous
semblait bon et sont ils sont projetés
paris s'est mesurée équilibrée tout en
sachant être servent de nombreux sujets
je pense par exemple aux diffuseurs
dignité des personnes
ce texte quelques détails au seul à
participer bien renforcer les principes
de notre république sans pour autant
renier leur terrain timité des croyances
et des pratiques religieuses de certains
de nos concitoyens
les travaux d'une commission pour fuir
cette ambition d'une réponse ferme à
certaines dérives constatées dans la
série culte mais ne rend pas stigmatiser
certains de nos concitoyens croyants et
pratiquants
car nous l'avons souvent rappelée dans
la majorité des cas la gare 6 du culte
se fait dans le respect des principes
républicains
celle là je crois qu'on court les deux
ces deux semaines de débats donc il faut
dire combien ils furent particulièrement
riche et intense et echirollois parfois
échappé du moins certaines décisions ont
donné à ces tests une tournure qui
n'avait pas il faisant perdre sa nature
consensuelle à l'essayer eu plusieurs
taden au débat d'abord celui de
l'intransigeance pas sérieux serbe et
notamment au service du service public
puis une parenthèse libérale au sujet
des structures domicile avec du recul
c'est tant mieux ans pourrait être
délicate justifié évidemment il ne
s'agissait pas de faire le moindre
compromis avec ceux qui s'attaquent à
notre rubrique et n'offrirait bien
commun c'est ce qu'il faut rechercher
c'était aussi le test d'unités une
grande loi qui donnerait un sentiment à
tout ce qui vous rend douter grave
unique et la voix du vivre ensemble que
les principes républicains d'exclure et
personnes aucune famille aucun homme de
notre collectivité nationale
il est à craindre que nous ils sont pas
parvenus se forger des rois contient
énormément de bonnes dispositions c'est
indéniable
mais il échoua essentiel répondants la
force de l'unité à ceux qui voudraient
nous séparer aussi même si nous
regrettons le groupe rdse à majorité ne
votera pas en faveur de ce texte
merci la parole est au président gontard
merci merci monsieur le président je
voulais revenir quelques instants sur ce
que disait ma collègue tout à l'heure
sur le climat dans notre pays qui est
particulièrement inquiétant et puis
c'est ces événements qui sont passés ce
week-end sur des lieux de culte
musulmans qui ont été vandalisés on est
on voit bien bien loin de hélas de
l'union on parlait de deux lignes de
crête je crois qu'un de nos collègues
par les deux lignes de crête j'ai plutôt
l'impression d'une dérive d'une large
dérive
le projet du gouvernement ça a été
rappelé était problématique à bien des
égards le texte qui va sortir du sénat
est hélas bien pire bien pire et c'est
une dérive totale est totalement
décomplexée mes chers collègues je me
demande dans quelle mesure vous réaliser
la portée de ce que vous avez voté au
delà du haro sur les mamans voilées ça a
été rappelé au delà de l'ignoble
suppression des allocations des
allocations familiales pardon pour les
familles d'enfants absentéistes
au-delà de vos lubies anti drapeau vous
avez tenté d'instaurer une police du
vêtement qui s'imposera à toutes les
religions
al'inverse des principes laïques d'
équilibre de 1905
la constitution ne vous permettant
heureusement pas dé dicter la loi pour
les seuls musulmans
voici vous amener cette surenchère et
cette dérive folle plus de vêtements
religieux pour les mineurs dans l'espace
public
fini les enfants tueurs en aube sur le
parvis des églises même l'uniforme scout
est menacée plus de liste communautaire
dans les universités que vont ni devenir
l'union et étudiants juifs de france ou
des jeunesse étudiante chrétienne plus
de signes religieux à la piscine et dans
les compétitions sportives nombre de nos
compatriotes sportives vont devoir
passer sur le bio se faire enlever au
laser leurs tatouages de crucifix j'en
passe et des meilleurs la liste est
longue et tristement longue le point le
journal le point qui s'est pourtant sa
une sur l'islam
une fois
par mois parle de concours lépine et de
fièvre sénatoriales il fut un temps où
le sénat se faisait au contraire une
fierté une fierté de sa modération et de
son rôle de garant des libertés
publiques
ce temps visiblement révolue dans le
sens de ce que disait tout à l'heure
pierre laurent ne distingue plus
tellement ici ce qui différencie une
partie de la droite radicalisée d'un
rassemblement national banalisée au bout
du compte
loin de conforter la république votre
projet de loi la saccagent la loi 1901
et corsetée celle de 1945 et piétiné
rien pour traiter séparatisme social et
c'est toute l'image d'un statut d'une
institution qui est vilipendé la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité jeu
nous voterons nous ne voterons pas ce
texte tout simplement parce que nous
sommes profondément républicain merci la
parole est à monsieur lagourgue
ainsi monsieur le président nous
achevons l'examen du projet de loi qui
doit nous permettre de lutter contre le
séparatisme alors que l'intégrisme s'est
progressivement développée en france
nous n'avons d'autre choix que de
réaffirmer que les principes de la
république doit être respecté par tous
l'égalité entre tous nos compatriotes et
notamment entre des femmes et des hommes
constitue l'un des fondements les plus
essentiels de notre société
ceux qui ne les respectent pas doivent
être sanctionnés la république ne cédera
pas face aux zones obscures et
obscurantisme quoi s'assurer du respect
de ces principes le texte prévoit de
nouvelles obligations et de nouvelles
procédures de contrôle nous nous
félicitons à cet égard que les
financements provenant de l'étranger
soit l'objet d'une attention
particulière ont trop longtemps des
puissances étrangères ont financé des
orgues des organisations hostiles sur
notre territoire il est nécessaire d'y
mettre un terme
le groupe les indépendants votre en
faveur de ce projet de loi nous serons
cependant très attentifs à son
application
il sera sans doute nécessaire d'en
dresser le bilan
après quelques années afin de nous
assurer que le dispositif reste efficace
et pertinent il faudra aussi veiller aux
moyens qui sont consacrés
l'application de ces nouvelles
dispositions l'administration sera
destinataire de nombreuses informations
elle devra avoir les moyens de les
traiter efficacement et d'agir lorsque
usées nécessaire merci si la parole est
à monsieur guay merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues se munissent nous avait
invités à débattre pendant quinze jours
du respect des principes de la
république
lorsque notre groupe a voulu parler des
séparatismes entre les riches et les
pauvres les la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale car l'impôt est un devoir
citoyen vous nous avez dit c'est pas
l'ordre du jour quand nous avons voulu
vous parler des discriminations que
subissent nos compatriotes en raison de
leur sexe de leur orientation sexuelle
ou de leur couleur de peau
vous nous avez dit c'est pas l'ordre du
jour et vous les avez même lignée quand
nous avons voulu parler de la république
qui doit s'incarner partout sur tous les
territoires dans les quartiers
populaires dans les territoires ruraux
et ultramarin par la présence des
services publics
vous nous avez dit ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour et lorsque nous avons
voulu parler des relations diplomatiques
que la france entretient avait certains
états qui financent eux-mêmes le
terrorisme il ya eu des sourires gênés
j'espère monsieur le ministre que vous
n'avez pas trouvé la droite sénatoriale
ici trop molle dans l'hémicycle
puisqu'un certain nombre d'amendements
stigmatisant nos compatriotes musulmans
ont été à l'ordre du jour j'y reviendrai
pas parce que la liste serait trop
longue mais de l'interdiction des pour
les mamans voilées d'accompagner les
enfants dans les sorties scolaires
jusqu'à l'interdiction des drapeaux dans
les mariages peu importe d'ailleurs il
est assez marrant de voir que ceux qui
parlent d'intégration à longueur de
journée n'ont eu de cesse que de vouloir
voter des amendements qui porte la
question de l'exclusion enfin un certain
nombre de camarades de collègues
pardonnez moi on ne parlait que la loi
1901 des camarades et collègues ont
parlé et ça va loin on parlait de la loi
de 1905 de la loi de 1901 qui est
échangé une question de liberté et je
voulais vous dire monsieur le ministre
que nous sommes très inquiet par exemple
par une disposition de cap a fait grand
bruit qui
mais qui à mon avis va dans les
prochains jours
amené à se débattre dans le pays sur la
loi 1901 liberté d'association le fait
que maintenant 17 millions de françaises
et de français qui vont demander une
licence sportive vont être amenés à être
fichés notamment par les préfectures sur
une question d'honorabilité est une
question qui nous pose grand débat sur
la question de l'inflation des fichiers
des libertés publiques et individuelles
vous voyez sur l'ensemble de toutes ces
dispositions
nous voterons contre ce projet de loi je
vous remercie et bien avant de donner la
parole au ministre je voudrais juste
rappeler à chacun pour se préparer qu'un
scrutin public demande et sur l'ensemble
du texte merci de vous y préparer
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
dire que son terminons ce débat de 15
jours en saluant tous les collègues du
gouvernement qui ont pu porter la parole
gouvernementale et jeu suivant vous
l'aurez compris également le même
travail à l'assemblée nationale il ya
peu je crois de textes qui font naître
autant de débats et dont on a la
pression que qu'ils vont changer
profondément les choses
non pas parce qu'on se paye des mômes
parce que le moment et est important et
est grave
moi je vais ramasser très sincèrement le
sénat des discussions que nous avons
eues depuis quinze jours en commission
comme ici dans l'hémicycle en dehors de
l'hémicycle comme dans les débats que là
on peut avoir politiques et techniques
parfois vif mais toujours je crois
respectueux
or version la commission des lois les
mesdames les rapporteurs les évidemment
et tous ceux qui ont contribué et
peut-être une légère différence
regretter les prises de parole
finalement deux d'explications de vote
qui ne correspond pas tout à fait si les
éditeurs de regarder et regarde les
débats depuis quinze jours à l'esprit de
concorde en tout cas de concorde
républicaine constatant qu'il y avait un
danger est que ce danger existe et
peut-être que toutes les solutions
n'étaient pas à la hauteur pour certains
où elle était trop importante pour
d'autres et qui correspondait au souci
du gouvernement d'ailleurs de ne pas
présenter un débat qui a été largement
parlementaire puisque moi d'une
quinzaine d'amendements ont été
proposées par le gouvernement et je
crois très respectueux
de ce débat tout à l'heure le sénateur
brisson nous rappeler qu' il fallait
être ni naïf ni excessif je pense que ça
a été la position du gouvernement et je
le constate il ya eu des excès que je
regrette notamment largement évoquée sur
les dispositifs qui nous paraissent en
effet contraire à la constitution
qui sont les dispositifs qui relève des
expressions religieuses article 10
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et il ya eu beaucoup aussi de
naïveté
considérant que simplement avec des bons
mots ne pourrions lutter contre l'hydre
qui nous combat je crois que la position
du gouvernement pour le coup et centrale
est à la fois ferme et reste conforme
aux principes républicains
de très nombreuses dispositions viennent
changer profondément parfois avec
l'appui de notre commission mesdames les
rapporteurs le travail que pourra faire
le médecin d'intérieur la justice
éducation nationale le mouvement des
élus locaux qui le réclamaient depuis
longtemps faire face à ces ingérences
étrangères où assa séparatisme je crois
qu'il ne faut pas oublier non plus
sous-estimer la révolution positive qui
remet au goût du jour la loi de 1905
bien au contraire de l'affaiblir elle la
renforce
mettant à disposition une police
administrative des cultes bien amélioré
et modernisé qui correspond à la fois
l'esprit du législateur de l'époque et
en même temps ouais la france
d'aujourd'hui
et puis nous avons longtemps discuté de
sujets qui je crois font honneur à la
république et qui nous permettent de
distribuer discuter sans stigmatiser à
quelques exceptions près monsieur ravier
vous avez plusieurs fois j'ai entendu
cet argument plusieurs fois dans votre
bouche dans le débat c'est à traire
rappeler que nous étions déconnecté nous
étions loin des préoccupations des
français
vous me l'avez répéter comme un mantra
si j'étais facétieux je vous dirais que
personnellement ayant été réélu à la
tête de la mairie je me sens pas
totalement déconnecté mais je voudrais
souligner que des propos excessifs que
vous portez ne font pas honneur au débat
que nous avons parfois et qui venant de
toutes parts on permettrait de pouvoir
améliorer les textes jour je crois
vraiment que la position que vous avez
tenue d une position politicienne et
qu'ils n'étaient pas conformes
semble-t-il échanges qu'on a pu avoir
précédemment en dehors des micros et des
caméras je le regrette profondément
je voudrais remercier chacune et chacun
d'entre vous pour ce débat dire que je
souhaiterais le plus possible une cmp
complet conclusive au nom du
gouvernement
simplement le gouvernement ne pourra pas
à accepter une cmp qui prévoira la non
expression religieuse dans l'espace
public
c'est une limite que j'avais déjà fixé
en discussion avec votre commission
avait que ceux présents du sénat avec
des groupes politiques
et si ce n'est pas le cas parce que la
cb malheureusement serait conclusive y
compris avec ses vêtements je crois que
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
dans une deuxième séance ce que je
regretterai mais que le gouvernement est
prêt à assumer monsieur le président
nous sommes très heureux de finir avec
l'ensemble je crois des collaborateurs
miss à elle que je serai ici remerciés
qui ont beaucoup travaillé quelles que
soient les cabinets quelles que soient
les administrations pour avoir ce débat
de parlementaires qu'ils espéraient
était de qualité
merci à vous monsieur le ministre pour
vos propos j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par les groupes les
républicains groupe crc eu sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans
l'intitulé est ainsi rédigé projets de
lois confortant le respect des principes
de la république et de lutte contre le
séparatisme
le scrutin est ouvert
cela nous demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
voici le reste
coutances en 12 sur l'ensemble du texte
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
317 pour l'adoption 208 contre 109
le sénat a adopté
[Musique]